life extension makes absolutely no sense
if we can't solve the problem of the
decay of our brains
[Music]
and Henry doctors spent their
professional careers trying to stop
people dying or
trying not to let disease win
in you you've had a long career in this
business do you feel that science has
changed this uh
there are many we often keep people
alive for Better Off Dead with severe
brain damage I mean it's a very very
complicated balance and we over treat
but there's no question of that but it's
very difficult not to
um as I said earlier you can't predict
what science might turn up
um from the genetic point of view we do
need to bear in mind but genetics are
incredibly complicated I mean even eye
color which we're taught at school is
genetically determined is controlled by
at least seven different genes working
together and even when you know all that
you can still only predict the 70
accuracy what the eye color will be
schizophrenia at least 100 genes are
involved in so if there's so it's very
unlikely
there's any simple genetic hack Master
Gene which will somehow slow down aging
but I just finished but the other point
it seems to me it does not make sense
to try to prolong life but without I'll
being able to fix Alzheimer's and
Dementia and when I try to see the good
side of my having Advanced cancer I
think well at least I won't have to live
long enough to become demented it sounds
like a joke but it's extremely serious
yes by the age of 80 we have about a 40
percent probability of dementing and
even this latest wonder drug achieves
pretty trivial slowdowns improvements so
I mean what's the point of living the
1500 if we're all demented yes you can
say yeah well you never know what sounds
my point is yes it might spending lots
of money Mr research might produce
results but I think they're much more
important things to spend money on yeah
so I completely agree with what you're
saying except that trying to fix why
we're aging fundamentally yeah that's
super hard that would mean remodeling
our entire metabolism and we're not
doing that this Century probably
but what you want to do is fix the Aging
damage and that might be a bottleneck
where we actually can do interventions
that doesn't require a lot of super
complicated no I agree with that I
accept that thank you cool we agree on
that and I do agree that yeah we should
totally fix dementia too there's so many
other things we need to fix to make a
long life worth living but it's still I
mean in terms of limited resources I
still think it's but isn't it great in
that case if it's the private money
rather than the public money going yeah
some of the private money being
accumulated by these billionaires and
oligos
it always has been rich people who've
been trying to imagine that they the
Last Frontier they can buy
instead they spent the money and said
we're gonna try to slow down the Aging
of the British citizens that's going to
save a lot of taxpayer money by reusing
they'll make me work till I'm like 85.
yes like I'm never getting out of the
NHS
most of us would say in and they're just
doing this would be a really weird thing
both politically and in practice and
many would say actually shouldn't you be
spending the money on the fractures and
the Midwifery so yeah there is actually
a benefit but Jeff is spending the money
on that and even Golf Course
notice but most billionaires the
billionaires we don't and have gone
they're spending it on nice fancy
mansions and jokes when people love
talking about the Elon Musk and FB so
because we're building rockets and
trying to cure aging and oh heavens
forbid Bill Gates is trying to cure
malaria What a wicked man we tend to go
for them because we're doing something
they weren't spending money as far as I
know on Aging researchers yeah he's
spending money on on malaria isn't there
an important Point as well are they
selling us the idea of Youth which sells
right you know we put our creams we put
our whatever you know the gym
memberships that's not about always
being healthy that's about feeling young
so I'll be saying we're aging people and
they feel young you know I fully sign up
to that are we aging people that feel
old but look young which is a really
different thing because you know your
Botox is a metabolic poison so you're
actually killing the cells that you're
trying you're pretending and looking
younger so and it all comes down to
let's get into feminism now but
essentially a lot of it is being sold so
that women feel bad about themselves and
look in the mirror and feel bad about
themselves we pay over some money to
some guy that's developing some fake you
know anti-aging groups absolutely but
they're so they're selling immortality
but actually it's it's
all of this is looking well that's you
know they're selling youth they're
selling new bile and prepubescent and
that's what people are buying into but
it's it's all about we're looking for
happiness in completely the wrong places
but to pick up on Anders point that if
if extremely rich people choose to
invest in extending life in this way
that's not actually damaging the rest of
humanity presuming that it will in the
end it is it is if they were charged
very high taxes and the money was spent
we have you have a two-tier even more so
you have the Divide between the rich and
the poor so the rich die
you know later and longer and allegedly
happy
because at least in the western
democracies people say we could save so
much money advantages if people are
aging more slowly we're totally gonna
buy the beef sauce method now the
problem is of course if that lifx ever
involves a lot of services you need a
lot of doctors and nurses to massage
your telomeres and do other clever
things then it might be so expensive
that is going to be very hard to
subscribe if it's small molecules then
the the once the patent run runs out
it's very cheap the idea that oh it's
always going to be super expensive
that's a bit like saying yeah cell
phones that's only going to be varelon
for the millionaires
and what happened was instead of course
that yeah we got the luxury ones and now
it's in more or less everybody's hand
and they're actually having the most
transformative effect in the developing
countries
so we want to avoid them to be maybe
trinked and linked to a lot of
complicated services but I do think that
we would have a tendency spread because
the way to become a trillionaire is of
course to be the one who has a patent of
Life exception
then you can start spending money for
some really weird things but but we go
back to does that bring happiness you
know can you name a trillionaire I can't
name any but can you name one that is
happy yes I know I personally know a
billionaire who is nice friendly dancers
rather well uh I'm single no I didn't uh
he actually also recently became a
grandfather but he is happy uh it's
interesting because I think there is
some truth to this our billionaires have
been their own businesses yeah very
happier than the poor people but no they
have their own problems and money
doesn't bring it happen a long life
doesn't bring you necessarily happen I
also don't think it brings you
unhappiness you need to do something
with it there's not this meaning there
is so much research showing the human
happiness Beyond a certain minimum
income is is socially determined it's
your sense of meaning and purpose your
social life your family you know that
this is that that's what brings
happiness well and that takes us neatly
to our third question which is if we can
imagine a world without debt
would it be desirable would it be able
to work
you're still at work
my first ever job was in a nursing home
and I was 16 and it worked nursing
homework I would say and I've worked
across the world in many different
contexts I would say it's one of the
toughest gigs about it is really really
thankless and I worked in a nursing home
that unless you paid the extra premium
we didn't change your sheets throughout
the night so whatever whatever you did
in the bed through the night through
dementia as we've talked about through
incapacity
um people were left in them unless they
paid the premium and I did put a
complaint in it was my first ever job as
a 16 year old and I put a formal
complaint into my local Council about
the nursing home and never got asked
back
um what a surprise what a surprise
um so we have to look at the quality of
life as a 16 year old I which you know
I'd like to think I was naive and
innocent and going into this job because
I thought I don't know I'd be helping
people
shave and be clean and have dignity
because we you know we talked about
dignity earlier what is life without
dignity it's we all deserve dignity
regardless of where we are on that
lifespan and it was a very sharp shock
into that many hundreds of thousands of
people in this country live a very
undignified life in care homes that are
unsubsidized we've all got a fight for
the NHS we've got to fight for our
social services which is completely
going down the pan at the moment so
unless we're going to sort out these
really fundamental systems of where are
we looking after these people us maybe
probably not maybe my kid
for their longevity of life we we're not
getting it right now so how on Earth can
we care and give dignified Lifestyles to
people if we're
increasing that population and
decreasing the workforce it's completely
impossible
well I spent five months working as a
nursing assistant and a psychotheriatric
Ward and a long-term mental hospital in
the South London and it it's it's an
education it really is so life extension
makes absolutely no sense if we can't
solve the problem of the the decay of
our brains yeah sure maybe that the
wonderful magical research will find a
solution to that but I think that's at
the moment one never know someone can't
predict but if you could suddenly get
everybody living a lot longer
they still have to die from something
um
so I
to continue watching this video click
the link in the top left or in the
description below or visit iai.tv for
more debates and talks from the world's
leading thinkers on today's biggest
ideas